- [Narrator] This is
Bermani, a martial eagle,
the largest African eagle.
They have enough power in one
foot to break a human arm.
As powerful as they are,
their strength in numbers
continues to decrease in the wild.
Martial eagles weigh
in at around 14 pounds,
with a wingspan up to
eight and a half feet.
Bermani is native to sub-Saharan Africa,
preferring open woods, wooded savannah
and thorn bush habitats.
He is an apex predator, sitting at the top
of the avian food chain.
Unfortunately, they are
being persecuted by humans,
mistakenly believed to be a
predatory threat to livestock.
In reality, domestic animals make up
a very small percentage of their diet.
Add to that a shrinking
habitat, which reduces prey,
the martial eagle population
is dwindling fast.
This is the martial eagle.
(ambient tones)